Let me take a second.
It's been a while since I
checked in with my good friend,
Andy Richter,
I'd like to see how he's doing.
Hey Andy, how are you?
Hi, Conan.
You are Conan, right? (laughs)
Yes (laughs)
We haven't seen each
other in a million years.
You rascal.
No, I'm doing okay.
I'm hanging in there.
It's just strange times.
Yeah.
Trying to find ways to stay busy.
What about you?
Ah, same.
Yeah, I mean, you know,
kids and dog and chores.
But yeah,
that's pretty much it.
You know, I was thinking
about the other day,
I know You're a baseball fan.
You must be looking forward
to the season starting up
in a couple of weeks uh.
I am a baseball fan,
specifically a fan of Korean baseball.
Their season started
months ago and I'm hooked.
You know Andy,
I didn't know you'd gotten
into Korean baseball?
Oh, how could I not!
It's literally been the
only live sport being played
in the world for the last three months.
Sure you have to stay up
till 2:30 in the morning
to watch the games,
but it's worth it when
you've got heavy hitters
like Yang Eui-ji,
helping the NC Dinos dominate this year
or or Yong-chan pitching
six straight no-hitters
for the Samsung Lions.
Of course,
you can't talk about pitching without
Chang-mo Koo and his 0.51 ERA this season.
He's a lefty too. Can you believe it?
That was incredible you know,
I can't believe you caught up this fast.
Ooh not as fast to as Sim
Woo-jun's dealing bases
for the KT whiz.
You know, the biggest problem I have
is that I don't have anyone
to talk about this stuff with.
I mean, especially all the controversy
with the Kiwoom Heroes.
Oh, you mean their owner Lee Chang-suk
was convicted of embezzlement, right?
Yes.
I mean, can you believe Yang Joon-hyuk
wants to return after all that.
Yeah with three DUIs on his record.
That sounds like the
perfect fit for that guy.
Well, Conan,
I had no idea you were into The KBO too.
Oh yeah, I'm a huge Doosan Bears fan.
♪ ( singing Doosan Bears song) ♪
Doosan Bears
Doosan Bears, yes
Doosan Bears, they're great.
Wow,
Hey Andy,
this is great.
Do you wanna watch the
KT whiz game together
tonight at 3 am?
Uh, it's okay.
I mean,
I actually like to watch it
by myself so I can really focus.
What?
What are you talking
about, this is perfect.
I mean, we get to hang out.
Oh, Conan you know, you're breaking up.
I my Wi-Fi is terrible.
I I think I'm not gonna have to
You have good Wi Fi, what do you...
Asshole